the Conservatives have turned their
focus in a different direction unveiling
a pledge to offer increase protection to
the workers should party win in June
Prime Minister Theresa May pledged to
continue raising the national living
wage currently seven pounds fifty an
hour in line with our journeyings until
2022
she also said she would introduce a
statutory right two years on paid leave
to care for a relative and would grant
new protection for workers pensions in
the wake of corporate scandals such as
the collapse of BHS for Karen and ferb
and his Director General of the CBI and
she joins me now so Carolyn your friends
over at the British chambers of commerce
today have said that the word about the
prospects and more costly and
bureaucratic new regulations did you go
along with that well I do think there
are things to welcome in here so as an
overall package so the guarantees around
the translation of European workers
rights into UK law in a time when we
need maximum certainty really important
the devil will be in the detail in some
of these recommendations we have got a
very vibrant labor market we've created
two million jobs since 2012 we need to
protect that actually I think there are
some areas where we were welcomed and
we'll hopefully see more evidence of a
focus on social mobility and not just
measurement what about this proposal for
allowing someone to take a year off to
care for a sick relative I mean it
sounds a wonderful thing but if you're
running a small business that's
potentially quite costly but I think I
think this is where the devil the devil
is in the detail I think that is
absolutely right for small businesses
that is challenging now I think the
ambition is a very good one we have an
aging society these are responsibilities
that many of us will have I think
employers are very sensitive to that
but I hope through a process of
consultation we can arrive at something
which will work for for all sides now
one of the other prepares you Teresa may
seems to have dropped finally this idea
of having the workers represented in one
board but she wants non-executive
directors every board to have a
non-exempt director tasks with looking
out for employees I mean not execs
aren't going to be falling over
themselves to take that well I think
although I think actually if you look at
what what has been proposed it is a
range of options and I think one of the
things that is very good about where we
are is that there
is no absolutely mandated answer so it
could be a non-executive director it
could be an advisory council or it could
actually be a worker representative so I
think the important thing is that
companies have options here and there is
nothing mandated they're also talking
potentially about blocking takeover bids
if it affects the sustainability of the
pension fund in future is that going to
throw grit in the wheel in terms of the
sort of M&A process we've got to be very
careful and I go back to the fact that
we've benefitted from being an open
economy and the world is watching us at
the moment in terms of some of the
signals about openness so I think we
have to be careful again let's look at
the detail I think that there are some
protections that could be effective and
there are others that will be damaging
so we just need to be very aware of our
brand globally and to keep that openness
at the forefront of our mind that's a
really interesting point that you raise
so what are the messages that are being
transmitted to the rest of the world in
your opinion I think overall that we are
remaining an open economy so we are
continuing to want to attract the the
best investment to our shores I think
it'll be very interesting when we see
the manifestos this week to see how
strongly that message has been heard
it's a very important time for us to
communicate our commitment to thriving
business to open economies to attracting
the brightest and best and it's an
opportunity for the manifestos to set
that out it doesn't really feel at the
moment as if any of the main parties are
talking that much about business or even
standing up for business I mean Jeremy
Corbyn for example wants to raise
corporation tax to resume here seemingly
adding layers of bureaucracy now who's
standing up for business in this case
well I think I can I think this is a
time for real pride in business actually
so in terms of the challenges that we
face and the opportunities it is going
to be the employers the investors the
creators of jobs the innovators that are
going to create the jobs of the future
and it is a time for pride in business
and again I very much hope that we will
see that from from both parties indeed
all parties when they reveal their
manifestos later this week it's a very
important time for our economy
presumably you're not overly infused by
the idea of a rising corporation tax so
I think
again signals around the world need to
be taken very seriously so we do know
that a competitive corporation tax rate
has been one of the drivers of inward
investment it has created great jobs and
we want to see more of it in the future
so again I think that is something which
we just need to be very careful about in
terms of the mix of tax measures that
are introduced